Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday.
Um,
October 21st,
2013.
How you're fucking doing. Why is
this such an echo in here? Hi.
Um,
I'm in a hotel room.
A splash fully furnished hotel room here.
That's why it's echoing a little
bit and it'll good. You know what?
This will help my awful singing,
you know? Oh, you'll know.
Dasher and dancer and Prancer and vixen.
Um, how are you? How was your weekend?
As you could tell him a little banged up,
a little banged up. Didn't get a lot
of sleep last night. You know what?
I've been in the phone
fog last 10 days. I was kidding.
Who lasts like 10 weeks.
I've been on the road.
I would work my ass off and a dad,
daddy's been taking his
medicine every night. And uh,
you know what? I'm in a fog.
I need to, I need to, uh, you know,
I need to turn over a new leaf here.
I got to become like that dude.
Remember those grape nup commercials?
We'd be outside and his fucking bathrobe,
you know,
one leg up on the fucking wouldn't see
couple of squirrels running around the
background. Some birds tweeting
and he's just eaten as grape nuts.
All clearheaded.
Right.
That's why I need to be all right.
I got to quit.
I sound like shit. Getting over a cold.
I'm a message this week everybody.
You know what, this should make you
feel better about yourself. You know,
we I at least I didn't uh,
didn't fucking Bay the way Ya
Bill Bandwagon did this weekend.
You guys have been
following me on Twitter.
That's my new character Bill Bandwagon.
I was joking on Twitter that the Boston
red sox signed the first free agent fan
to a three week contract. We'll
bandwagon and that is make an I am him.
Bill Bandwagon does what
bill bandwagon dough.
I will actually went over to the red sox
pro shop here in Boston and I went over
to it.
Um,
okay.
Well during the, whenever the fuck we were
playing Detroit this past weekend, uh,
I walked into the pro shop and I
literally, I got sick to my stomach.
How weird is that?
Cause I bought so much red sox shit
right up during the whole height of that
curse to the babe shit trying to end
that fucking 86 year drought.
I have more red sox shit then.
I don't think I'll ever
have to buy any more.
I mean if they win the championship, I'm
guessing. I'm definitely gonna buy a hat.
I L I like getting the world series
patch, but that, that that's about it.
Maybe a shot glass. Your shot Mike
yet. But as far as jerseys, dude,
I got d I still in mind the back of my
closet. I have Derek Lowe tee shirt,
Manny, Manny, Ramirez
Jersey. No Ma fucking jersey.
Okay.
Somebody
got me a jersey.
That was like the old school red sox won.
It just said Papi on the front of it.
Like I'm ever going to fucking wear that,
but I can't throw it out,
you know.
So the last thing I fucking need to do
is go into a store and get more of that
shit that, that is going to become
sentimental and then I can't throw it out.
So,
uh,
I went by there again today to see if
they had the world series patches and they
don't, I guess they get them
tomorrow. Some shit, I don't
fucking know. So anyways,
congratulations to the Boston red sox.
I can actually name a few now.
Go around the infield a little bit.
Was In Middlebrooks over to drove over
to Petrolia and I don't know who plays
first base.
Is it Napoli or was he out of left field?
I don't fucking know. Salting, Yamaka.
And then there's those two Asian guys
who would just fucking killing him.
I can't remember the guy's name. It begins
with a u and he's fucking lights out.
But [inaudible] it's so sad that I haven't
watched this year and I have to sit
here like a housewife who's been doing,
doing needlepoint all year and
acting like I get it. I don't get it.
I don't know what's going on. I've been
here in Boston the last five days and uh,
I'm actually reading the sports page in
this hell fucking nuts and spices like
Dan Shaughnessy, like three days in
a row wrote a positive, a article.
It's incredible. But whatever.
Let's just get down to brass tacks.
You the red sox won the world series.
Unbelievable fucking series.
We had to win game six. I just said we,
I know I did. I'm a fucking hypocrite.
They had to win game
six because they would,
there's no way there'll be in Berlin
to twice, so thank God they did.
And thank God that guy hit that Grand
Slam and he punched himself from the
checks just right. Like that
chick was sins. Sings the, uh,
the titanic song, right? Oh wait,
that's Whitney Houston. Well,
what was the titanic song?
Ugh.
I was just a song that
made you hate women.
You know, you have a do that. You
just really, I don't know if women,
if you ever do,
did you,
is there a song that comes on
that just makes you hate guys?
Yeah.
Eh,
a bunch of fucking meathead had guys,
bunch of peanuts around the
peanut shells around their feet,
sitting there screaming and yelling,
right?
Standing over there in the corner
with his shit. Stain draws,
drinking beers like it. This has to
be a fucking song like that for me.
The male version.
It was whatever that titanic song was
and that stupid mere cat that sang the
fucking thing and she'd punch
yourself in her little hollow chest.
Oh God,
the fuck was her name.
And then she dated and she'd married
that landscaped fucking coke dealer slash
maybe did some porn at some point
in his life directed at anyways,
that Boogie nights looking guy had
one of those really fucking, uh,
a feminist French names like Renee
or Susan or some shit,
right?
Jackie, whatever the fuck his
name was. Jesus am I a mood?
Listen to me trashing
that, that fucking, uh,
the female George Saint
Pierre of Canada right there.
Basically on the same level.
One can choke you out.
The other one, uh, chokes you
up. There you go. Look at that.
That was poetry right there.
I'm summing up Canada. Everybody
know Gigi. Um, anyways,
I found a sick Gab la when I was here in
Boston. I got to lay off that shit, dude.
I swear to God, I look phenomenal for
my age, but if I live another week,
the way I've been living the
last six weeks, all right,
I'm going to catch up to it.
What Ron Howard looks like and I'm
going to go right by him, you know,
and that's no disrespect to Ron. Okay.
That guy's like in his sixties, isn't he?
Or is he in his fifties? I
don't fucking know. Whatever.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody,
the Boston Red Sox are in the world
series against the St Louis Shit,
birds and a red bird. Sorry. Why?
Why would you start with them?
They're very nice fence. Very nice fans
out there in the home of Anheuser Busch.
Um,
and I got to tell you something right now.
I cannot name one person on their team.
He says the most baseball I've watched
since I stopped watching in 2010.
I don't know anybody on that fucking team
who's pitching for, he had John Today.
Who Do you got over there?
Huh?
Did that guy who finally
shaved his fucking head? No.
Wait, you traded him to, uh,
the angels and then from
what I've overheard,
he's been shitting the bed out there.
What the fuck is his name? I Dunno.
I don't fucking know. But
you know, I'm going to watch,
you know what's the hardest thing about
trying to fucking watch the red sox and
get all caught up is they all look
alike. What? Those fucking beards?
There's like three of them.
They look,
they're the exact same
length and color beard.
And then there's the backup catcher or
whatever, but he's got the gray in it.
I don't, I don't fucking know. I
don't pretend to know. All right,
but if you think I'm not going to
be standing there on the child's,
is the duck boats go by like
I've been there all fucking year.
You're sadly mistaken. Yes you
are. All right, let's get out.
Let's get out of the hole.
A sports thing.
This is a story than tricked me.
Did you guys,
did you such a hate that fucking word?
I saw it and I was intrigued.
You know,
like the whole world should be rejoicing
that you're fucking fascinated.
Just say sparked your interest,
you were intrigued. Uh,
what a self serve and fucking word that
is. That's a deal breaker right there.
If you're ever on a date and somebody
uses that word on a first date,
unless you're a fucking Douche
and you want an, you know,
maybe cancel out your douchey
penis, you know, like two negatives,
make a positive and maybe a baby
will come out and be a good shit.
I'm telling you right now, steer clear
of anybody ever uses the word intrigued,
you know,
as if they're artsy.
Fucking glasses didn't give
themselves away to begin with.
The second that word comes
out of their mouth, you know,
and if you can't do the math on
that, I can't fucking help. Um,
here's a story that
just piqued my interest.
If you guys seen this shit
about the Greenpeace 30,
basically 28 Greenpeace guys,
ladies,
whenever the fuck you call
them greenpeacers and two
journalists for some stupid
fucking reason, they
decide. They just decide,
okay,
out of the fucking blue to go over,
up into the Arctic circle.
All right.
And basic. What the F I gotta I gotta
say this right. Basically what they did,
they tried to board,
okay.
More than a month ago after Russian coast
guards seized 28 Greenpeace activist
and two journals,
journalists in the Arctic waters following
their attempt to board a Russian oil
rig. These guys got,
these guys had a meeting.
These 28 people had a fucking meeting
and they were like, all right,
here's the plan to help
save the environment.
Or at the very least try to slow down
the changing of the environment because
there's always going to be an environment,
you know,
taking one from George Carlin there.
They'll will always be in an
environment which just changing.
So they don't like the direction
that some of the other human beings,
the effects they have. And I want to
say decide that they can, I don't know,
try and stop these guys from drilling
in this area that Greenpeace feels
they shouldn't be drilling it.
So this sitting there in the war room
drawing up these plans. All right.
And I'm just picturing myself
in this fucking meeting cause I,
I don't have a problem with Greenpeace.
It out.
Looks like a very thrilling job.
Sit this zig zag and in front of a
fucking whaling ship, wind in your hair.
You know people from other
lands shaking their fist at you.
That sounds like a hell of a fight.
It sounds way better than tying
yourself to a tree going, come on, man.
You know, it just seems like,
you know, it's a good time.
So if I ever a green peace,
I could see myself getting sucked into
a position where I'm in that meeting.
All right,
so now you're in the fucking meeting.
Somebody up there who God knows who man
or a woman is up. They're gone. All right,
so we're going to go up to the Arctic
circle right there. I'm like, all right,
that's going to be fucking cold.
What is it?
It's October the fucking planet starting
to tilt away from the sun up there.
I don't know about this.
Are we going up there on an ice breaker?
Um, that's my first concern. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, blah, blah, blah.
And now we're going to go fuck with
the Russians. Whoa. Right there.
I'm looking around the room.
Then you just say,
[inaudible] am I going to fuck with the,
my whole life was a childhood.
Those were the guys you didn't
want to fuck with. You know what?
Fuck the Russians.
You know?
This isn't like you're going to go over
there and you're going to go mess with
the, I dunno, fictional buddy.
The Estonians.
Who the fuck knows anything about Estonia?
I don't stone here. What are they
doing over there? They eat people.
They don't eat people off. Fuck it.
Let's go over this. Go mess with him.
The second you say Russians, I'm
like, wait a minute. What is this?
And then they get to the fucking point.
Yeah.
Then we're going to
pull up to the oil rig.
We're going to shoot some ropes up it
like we're in an action movie and we're
going to start climbing up the side of
it and we're going to board their oil rig
right there. I'm out. I'm
not fucking doing that shit.
You outta your mind.
We're going to get shot.
So many is going to take a fucking meat
cleaver, right as we get up to the top.
I'm going to pour hot water.
A fucking oil on us.
Yeah.
So anyways,
these fucking jerk offs get on this
goddamn boat and then two journalists go
with them to cover it
and they fucking nature they take go out
there and what exactly what you would
have thought.
What happened happened plus fucking
like Russian navy seal looking guys with
these fucking awesome guns
pointed at these, these people,
they arrested all of them. They took
their boat and the two journalists,
the Greenpeace guys are saying that the
fucking boat was in international waters.
Gives a fuck. You're at the top of
the planet. There's no straight sex.
Yeah. What are you looking at?
You a little fucking watch. Oh,
we're on this longitude, this
latitude. Nobody gives a fuck.
You just tried to board our oil
rig. All bets are off. So anyways,
they all got arrested in,
they're being charged with piracy
and they're beside themselves.
They're just saying, yeah, the
Russians just don't seem to understand.
And it's like, no, no, no, no. You
don't understand. You fucking morons.
You don't,
you don't do shit like that.
Yeah.
Find my neighbor was planting some ugly
bushes and his yard and I wanted to
protest. I wouldn't try to fucking repel
into his living room. And then when they,
they arrest me for fucking
breaking and entering,
I wouldn't be all what? Playing the
victim being like, dude, what the fuck?
What are you talking about that
was protesting your, your shrubs.
You just don't seem to
see it to app to see,
I have the same sense of humor
about this that I do. So, uh,
okay.
Yeah. So I, I dunno, like
everybody's feeling like
talking about this.
Like they're the victims.
It says the organizer,
the organizer,
the organization's UK executive director
has worked every weekend since the
incident in the Pecora. See, while Lee, I
hope I said that right, the [inaudible],
the [inaudible] to see while leading
efforts to secure their release,
but it's still finding
it difficult to sleep.
He's in a constant rush or interview,
blah, blah, blah. I said Russia,
he said Russia is sending out a clear
signals saying hands off are part of the
Arctic and hands off complaining about
our right to drill for oil there.
I think the same,
something a little more than that.
Don't fucking show up to an oil rig.
Like, like you got Tom Cruise on the boat.
You get to do some mission
impossible shit. This is the
real world. Jesus Christ.
You guys know how dumb I am,
right?
I know not to go out on a fucking boat.
Hey,
try and board a Russian oil rig.
You know,
we'd just be like that guy
and platoon the whole time.
I got a bad feeling about this man
sweet going out there listening to the
Mamas and the Papas, some hippy shit.
All right.
The leaves are Brown. Ah, the sky is gray
and these fucking guys started
screaming at you in Russian.
Yeah.
Do the guns.
They had pointed at him with a shit.
I got to tell you that right now. I
think that was the, uh, the game over,
I think it was called the game over 9,000.
That's what the fuck they
were pointing at him. So, uh,
you know, what are you going
to do? There's a lot of
dumb ways to go to prison,
but a, that I got to say that's
that. That's right up there.
How awful is it to get
arrested for piracy?
And you didn't even fucking take
the time to dress up like one. Yeah.
You know,
the only saving grace I'd be looking at,
the only way I'm going on this mission
is if I get that fucking hamburglar
striped shirt.
Put a patch over my eye and some
sorta cutlass and my fucking mouth.
Is that a knife? Is that a gun? I
don't fucking know. What do you,
what he called it? One
of those, one of those.
It's not a sword to fat or it's like
a meat cleaver that got an erection.
Stick that right in your fucking mouth.
It's very phallic.
And then you climb up to Saigon.
Ire, ire. If I can. Hey Chef,
really any arctic Mekhi um,
but instead you fucking climbing
up the side. One, two, three.
We don't want you Julian for oil. Okay.
All right. Easy guys. Hands up everybody.
Jesus heard they're
serious. Um, all right,
let's get to some advertising here for
this week. The Greenpeace 30 everybody.
Let's try to keep up on that one. Can
you believe it? Who would have thought?
Who would have thought you couldn't
fucking just pull up to an oil rig,
all the fucking ocean, dude,
you couldn't do that to Exxon.
The very least someones gonna pee on
you as you're climbing up the side.
Somebody far enough from the ocean.
So you might even take his shit.
I don't think cell phone cameras work out
there because of the Bermuda triangle.
Dollar Shave Club. Everybody. Oh yeah.
I talk about this every damn week.
Um,
there's so many things in
the world that irritate me.
Hippies boarding a Russian oil rig and
getting charged for piracy and then
sitting there staring at their Bergen
stock, shaking their head going,
I don't understand.
Do you like how much I'm stereotyping
them that they're like this.
I'm sure they're hippies. Two Point
Oh whatever. What else bothers me? Um,
the red sox beards. I can't tell one
from the other that's been bugging me.
And um, I went to my, my,
the way I've been living my life lately,
very unhealthy. That's been bugging me.
But listen to that with all that things
with so many things out there that can
irritate you. Why would you add razors
to the list? You fucking moron. Come on.
Do the math here. It's time to
stop milking your razor blade.
I know with brand name razors,
you know what you used to.
You used to pay an outrageous prices
and exhausting those raises until they
start to look like a rusty soda can and
should drag it across your face there.
It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
You never have to think about it again.
They send a pack every month so you
can change your blades every week.
I love these guys and your
face will love them too.
They also have a new product
called one wipe Charlies.
It's about white from men
and you know what I say?
It's about time and it's
classy. Oh, is it class? He is.
Stick your pinky out as you're wiping
your bum there a check out the video for
that. It's hilarious. And
sign up for your razors today.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash
bur bur that's dollar shave club.com
forward slash bur bur or go
to billboard.com and Click
on the dollar shave club
banner. All right, Hulu.
Plus everybody you know last
the last couple of weeks.
I keep saying that they have breaking
bad on there and you know what?
Evidently they don't.
So why don't I actually go to the frigging
website and try and look it up here.
Let's see what they got going on here.
When you first try one week free.
Jesus Christ, help me out here. How
am I supposed to figure this out?
Go fuck yourself with everybody
trying to get you information. Um,
you know I tried to rent a bicycle
here in Boston. Yeah, I did that.
I did that. I was going to ride
a bike and I felt good about it.
And you guys can say anything
you want about me. I don't care.
I like riding bicycles and cities and
when I ride on my like go and Cerullo La
is, I go by pedestrians waiting
through a waiting to cross the street.
It makes me smile. So anyways,
they have these, you know,
that they have in New York City,
you know those city bikes,
unless you're in a rich neighborhood
and they don't want bicycles in the
neighborhood,
it's,
you know what's so amazing about
rich people is just how much they
just don't want to be around other
people. And you know, I, I 100% get it.
I fucking respect that. The Fuck
Outta here. Your animals. All right.
Do you think I stole all his fucking money
to listen to you getting on and off a
bicycle? Get the fuck Outta
here. You're a piece of shit.
And I took your 401k right.
Anyways, Hulu plus everybody.
No, Kim. So I um, look, get back to that
in a second. So I got a rent this bicycle.
Okay.
So I'm like, all right,
what's, what's the deal?
I got stick my credit card and the
bike thing, so I go ahead and do it.
And uh, then all of a sudden
they want my phone number.
Yeah,
I'm just riding a bike.
You already have my name and my credit
card number. You know who took the bike?
What do you need?
My phone number four.
Okay.
You know who I am. You know when I took
it, you know I didn't bring it back.
Okay.
You have my credit card that's going
to link it to where the fuck I live in.
That's it. It's over. I got, I
got to give you the bike back.
Why do you want my fucking credit?
I my phone number.
Fucking conch.
They just can't make it.
It's not enough to make
some money off the bike.
Now they've got to get one more
piece of information out of you.
So then they can then stockpile all
those numbers with your credit card
information and then sell them
to the fucking tell him McKinnis.
So I said, you know what? Fuck you
bicycle. I'm not bicycle company.
I'm not using it, so fuck them. I don't
know if they do that in New York City,
but I'm not renting a
bike. And uh, in Boston,
don't give him your phone number.
You asshole.
I wonder if I could have just made up one.
Okay.
I'm really big on misinformation.
You know when you can get away with it.
Always put out other information about
yourself. Give yourself a chance.
All right,
Hulu plus everybody.
You've probably tried hulu.com
and that was Hulu plus.
You can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit TV shows and a selection of a claim.
Movies on your television or on the
go with your smart phone or tablet.
That's the amazing thing about this.
Everybody.
This is really like watching TV in the
future. Like even when I was a kid,
I never even dreamed that you
could do something like that.
Just walk around watching TV
everywhere. It's awesome. Um,
extremes in HD for the best
viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite TV
shows, current TV show, excuse me,
like Saturday night live community,
family guy in Zillion Morris.
Or you can also watch some original
programming that a Hulu originals,
I should say like the awesome starring
Snl Seth Meyers and moon boy starting
Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids who will
plus also offers a great selection of
acclaimed films for only seven 99 a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and
movies as you want, wherever you want.
This is the future people.
This is how you watch TV right now.
You can try Hulu plus free for two weeks
when you go to Hulu plus.com/bill all
in caps, B I l l, all in caps,
right? Uh, a special offer
for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so
you can get an extended free trial and
they'll know that we sent you.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill a click on Hulu
plus all the Hulu plus banner on the
podcast page. I'm on Bill
bird.com. All righty,
so back to the fucking podcast.
A European trip is coming
up. Everybody. Rumor has it,
rumor has it,
my agent was talking to me.
I think we're going to add not as
second but a third show in London.
And uh, for all you people have been
sending me emails from Manchester, um,
England, uh, don't worry, I'm not,
I don't have time this time to do
it in the schedule cause I have to,
I think I go to Scotland the next day,
but without a doubt,
I promise you when it comes through
next year, I am going to go,
I'm going to do a show in
Manchester. I just a, you know,
it's a fucking zillion miles.
It's an ocean away.
I didn't know how it was
going to sell tickets,
so you always go to the
major cities and um,
I've just gotten a bunch of people saying,
calling me a cunt,
telling me to come to Manchester and
you know, that's all I need to hear.
That's all I need to hear. A little bit
of interest, a little bit of insults.
And I'm like, I like these guys. I'm
going to go fucking head up there. Um,
now I'm,
now forgive me for being stupid,
but Manchester is that where man
United is from? It's gotta be right.
That's crazy. To me, you
would think that the,
the most successful a premier
league team would be in London.
Does that make sense? Rather
than being in the worster of, uh,
of England,
I'm really,
I'm really fucking on two levels
stepping on a landmine here.
I'm talking sports when I don't even
know what the fuck I'm talking about and
I'm shitting on cities and I have no idea.
Okay.
Yeah.
Jesus Manchester,
is that one of those train spotting
towns where I'm gonna go there and get
fucking headbutted and
have my ear bit off.
I really don't want to deal with that.
That's why I feel safe in London.
I just feel like it's a bunch of people
skipping around drinking tea and a,
I'm not going to get beat down.
You know, that's not on my agenda.
Taken up soccer hooligan,
fucking beat down.
I'll tell you,
a long time ago,
I read that book among the thugs and uh,
I'm sure it was exaggerated or even worse.
Maybe it wasn't.
Maybe they toned it down, but uh, yeah,
that was enough for me. That was
enough for me. All right. Anyways,
I'm just fucking with you guys. I
will, I'll definitely, um, you know,
the more cities I can have one ad when
I go over there and the more shit I can
see, the more people I can reach. Each
time I go over to, to, uh, Europe,
I'm just going to keep adding countries
and cities and that type of thing.
That's the game plan and a, I'm
sticking to it. Oh, by the way,
you guys all talked me out of
going to Naples. Jesus Christ.
I might as well set. I was
going to fucking Dayton, Ohio.
I've never heard a city get trashed.
Trashed.
Fucking voice is cracking here
the way Naples did. Okay. Enough,
enough said. Enough
said. I got it. I got it.
So I think I'm going to
stay in Rome and then Kinda,
I think Florence got some good reviews.
Venice got some good reviews and having
really should do is look at dirty water.
I got to go somewhere.
Hey,
does anybody know a good book on
Mussolini? Can recommend a good one.
I've just read so much shit about that
guy. He reminds me of Paul Versey,
you know,
they both have a shaved head.
They both think they see things and they
both predict shit and they prepare for
victory and then they lose.
Um,
and it's it Benito Versie,
Paul Mussolini.
I told you that day when he fucking Ivy,
he was either invading someplace in
northern Africa or he was going in Greece
and Hitler told them, don't
do that shit. All right.
Yeah.
And, and mousseline he's like, yeah, I
don't why we got this. It's all good.
He goes out and he buys a white
horse to ride through town,
getting ready for the victory
party and then they lost
it. He's got that big dumb horse. He's
got nothing to do. What are you toe?
He's already though. It's going
to be a bloodbath. I got it.
So I want to read more about this guy.
Um,
he sounds like quite the character.
Speaking of characters,
um, there's a fucking
hilarious, hilarious video.
Only because it's all,
it seems like they're just
everybody's drunk and lethargic. Uh,
the name of the video is jet Fan Punches,
female patriots fan in the
face after their victory.
Congratulations to the green
country, by the way. Um,
that is your Superbowl and you know it is,
you're not winning it again this year.
You guys realize you're coming up on
your 50th anniversary of not winning a
super bowl, like the, your golden
anniversary. You know, and they,
and they said it wouldn't last.
Congratulations when you
guys don't win it this year.
This is me just pissed
because you guys won. Um, no.
You guys jumping around like you did
something yesterday. Ah, you wait,
you wait til we come back healthy.
You fucks. Um, and that was an excuse.
And you know what?
When you're losing the number one
fucking defensive player on all levels,
Vince Wilfork fucking
Mayo and a key to leap.
I gotta tell you, Geno Smith, dude, that
fucking guy, he bet again, a nickname.
You Dumb New Yorkers after
you've fucking said San Shies.
Can you give one to
Jane? Oh, you know what?
Don't don't jinx the guy because that
guy looks like he's the real deal. Man,
I really liked that guy as a quarterback,
Matt and I don't give a fuck man patriots
on winning shit this year anyways.
You know, I don't mean that in a
bad way, but I'm a realist. Okay.
I'm still enjoying the season
fucking cons. Um, anyway,
so it's at the end of the game.
And so the name of the video is like
basically mail, jet fan punches,
female Patriot's fan in face.
What it really should have
said was mail jet Fan Punches,
female patriots fan in the face after
female Patriot's fan was punching him in
the face for some reason.
You know,
because you're not supposed
to hit a woman in the face.
Whenever they show these videos,
they GE the cutout,
that part of the video or they show it
and the people on TV never commentate on
the fact that the woman was
punching this guy in the face.
Dude, you gotta see this jets
fan. It's fucking hilarious.
He's so shit faced and like lethargic.
That's the thing,
because everything is
just sorta like in slowly
motion round house. And uh, he
takes a lot of punishment, buddy.
He never, uh, he never loses focus.
I call them the big unflappable.
If you watch them, you know, Tim
Duncan is the big fundamental,
this drunk jet fan was,
was the big unflappable.
And I gotta tell you that female pats fan,
she took that punch like a
chip pop right back up. Um,
I don't know what was going on,
but that jet fan,
I don't know if he did something.
It starts right there at
the beginning of the video
does something and then it looks like
two ladies and some fat guy in a blue
shirt.
I'll kind of swinging on him and he's
just like in slow motion like girl put a
but button, just punching people
in the face. And uh, I dunno,
he obviously shouldn't have done it
and deserves to be punished. But uh,
this is something I think that I've asked
before of a female fans on this. Yeah.
Gas, if I have any. Um,
how do you feel about that?
Obviously you should never
punch a woman in the face,
but no. You know what? Fuck this.
Let me ask a better question.
Any women listen to this podcast?
Have you ever just gotten mad at a guy
in a bar and just started punching him in
the face and when you're doing
that are punching him in the head.
When you're doing that,
is there any fear that the
guy's going to hit you back?
Are you literally thinking like, well, you
can't eat, I'm a lady, you can't hit me,
I'm in the safety zone.
Or are you just simply so mad you lost
your shit and you just throwing punches?
Because, um, like I said,
I don't think that that jet fan
should had done what he did,
what he should've done.
What a gentleman does when a woman is
punching him in the face is you go with,
you go with the front
kick at like 30% speed.
You go with the front kick, 30%
power. That's what you do. It's so,
it's not quite a kick. It's sort of
just pushing her off. You, you know,
you just sorta,
you just kind of give one of those,
keeps her at bay leg is
longer than the arm, you know,
but then there's that thing where you
got to do it fast enough because the
second you do it, you know, some guys
are going to come in and totally,
because you actually made physical contact
with this human being that does not
have a penis, has a vagina yet is
throwing punches at you. It's really,
it's a really weird dynamic. But, uh,
I gotta tell you the big unflappable.
He did all right.
He's got it. He's got to wear a
jets jersey. He's got something.
You guys got to pull some money together
after you bail them out and you got to
get him a jets Jersey and on the back
he got to have the big unflappable.
Um, I dunno some he's probably going to
get mad at. There is no excuse whatsoever.
I'm not saying there is
okay,
but I just, I dunno. I find that,
that that dynamic is interesting.
Um,
I dunno,
I heard a great guy fucking bomb the
other day just walking down the street.
Just the way he was begging was great.
He had some sort of musical background
and you went, you walked by him,
he had his great voice and
you just go, James, James, j,
j j change.
I can't even do it the way it did.
It put a smile on your face.
He just went right down the scale.
I didn't have any money. I only
had fucking ATM money, you know,
so you got like a couple of twenties in
your pocket and he's like, all right,
I want to help you but do it. I'm
not trying to help him, you know?
Okay.
Trying to get you a sandwich. I'm not
trying to fucking buy you, you know?
I don't know. What can you get with
20 minutes at 20 bucks is a bit much.
Yeah.
Have you ever given a homeless guy like,
uh,
like five bucks or 10 bucks and they
react the same way as if he gave him a
quarter and you kind of get mad kind
of adjacent Alexander moment where you
wanted to get credit for. Then you
also think like, well, you know,
if I don't have a house or an apartment,
okay,
you know,
getting $5 really is not a
major step in that direction.
It's just,
okay,
maybe I can get the egg and
Swiss, you know, the ham and egg,
I can get a ham, egg and cheese
as opposed to an egg and cheese.
And then I'm going to eat that and then
in 90 minutes I'm going to be fucking
hungry again. So I kind of get it,
but it's also kind of annoying.
Jj, JJ, Jj, Jj, Jj, Jj, um, so anyways,
world series starts tomorrow night.
If you want to jump on my bandwagon,
I have the Shiny as bandwagon, the
newest and Shiny as bandwagon and town.
Um, oh dude, I got no fucking arguing with
someone. Rarely bill bought a surprise.
Don't come at me with that attitude.
All right.
I've got this big argument
with somebody the other day.
They were telling me
all about Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Talking about a fake tits and all
that type of thing was making,
you know,
and nose jobs and you know,
I went out to la we,
but he's still plastic
and fake out their paper.
The just like a year fucking more run.
Okay.
Yeah. And everybody back
here, just the truth, right?
Is that what you're telling me? Fucking
blows my mind. It just really does.
And that's just like,
you know what kills me as I've lived out
there for six years and I'm like, look,
I know when you first get there,
I know what you do.
You go down fucking sunset strip,
you go down Hollywood boulevard.
Yeah. And that's what you see. Okay.
You're telling me when you go to the
fucking meatpacking district in New York
City,
it's not a bunch of plastic,
phony fucking Paris Hilton
types or whoever the fuck
the new one is of that ilk.
Yeah. You go to the fucking club
scene with the beautiful people.
It's always going to be a bunch of
phony people. But I got to tell you,
I don't think the plastic
surgery is that bad in la.
And I know all you guys were
like, oh, like, and what do
you even react to it too?
Yeah.
Have you fucking bet this guy.
I lived out there for fucking six years
and I'm telling him go through it.
It's really not like that.
There's a lot of really talented
good people out there. So,
yeah. Yeah. What the fuck do
I know? I just live out there.
You've been out there six days.
I've been up there six years.
What the fuck would I know? Please? By all
means. You tell me about what you know,
I'm somehow missing.
I have got to be honest with you.
If you really want to see plastic
surgery, that's out of control. Um,
okay.
These are my top three places. And
then there's, uh, my, my wildcard pick,
I would say Orange County,
California, Dallas, Texas,
and um,
okay.
Miami Beach, Florida.
Unbelievable. And then my, my,
my wildcard.
Okay.
The impossible dream. What might
be a, I would say Phoenix, Arizona.
But the fake tits. Um, but even
then I think fake tits are out,
you know, like roller blades, they were
there like a 90 thing. At the very least.
They don't have them like a,
you remember those ones they had
in the nineties. Oh Jesus Christ.
Those fucking Clint Eastwood
Vein on the side of,
yeah.
Women fortunately stopped doing that.
Okay.
There's never been a pair of fake boobs
that looks better than the real thing.
Then whatever the, the original
real boobs just look way better,
regardless of size, way better.
You know what I mean? I Dunno.
I guess when you have a shirt on,
nobody can tell, but I don't, I don't
know the fuck. That's just weird.
That's fucking insane.
To take a plastic bag of
chemicals and stick that in. Yeah.
Rather than keeping your
beautiful normal ones.
I'm pro boobs than me talking nicely
about boobs here in October. Oh,
by the way, uh, I called
it with the pink scam.
It's finally fucking coming out.
You guys see in all these articles,
this is all that pink shit,
all that ways where need to up kitchen,
stove. How can you make of it?
Everybody coming down on me.
You think I'm the bad guy. I'm wearing
the black hat and fucking October,
I got a link for you guys to
check out that I, I swear to God,
a hundred people have tweeted to me,
so it's not my fine,
I'm not going to take credit for it,
but this is how it works with
that pink shit. It's basically
whatever they sell. So let's say they
sell a pink Football Jersey, Nfl Jersey,
you buy a Tony Romo Pinky, right?
Commie Pinko fucking Jersey,
right?
Basically like 10% of the wholesale,
not the retail price on the Jersey.
Now what you pay the 8,000 bucks,
whatever the fuck it is, the
wholesale, which is probably,
we'll say 35 bucks maybe.
What does it cost them after the kidneys?
The sweatshop makes the fucking thing.
I don't know, we'll just say 35 bucks.
So 10% of that.
Yeah.
So if it's a $100 Jersey retail for you,
10% of the wholesale,
35 bucks,
that's like they donate $3 and 50 cents
and then they pocket the other $96 and
50 cents and then it goes over to
the Commie Pinkos there. Right.
They take that $3 and 50 cents now
they have their entire infrastructure.
Yeah.
On all the people that are making money,
trying to ways that raise awareness.
Like that's their job.
That's how they pay their rent.
That's how they get themselves a yacht.
That $3 and 50 cents has to be thrown
into the stockpile to pay all those people
for their pink cubicles in this
pink staplers and all of that shit.
And by the end of it,
I don't know what you have left.
So there you go.
There you go.
It's just one big C is shit.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck. I
don't, I really don't mind.
It's one of the dumbest things
I've ever seen in my life.
I think people are aware of it and I
just find it to be this weird thing where
you have to be that aware of it.
Like it's more important than,
it's like they're jockeying for
positions in like, you know,
this disease march madness,
you know,
they're running up the score so they
can get the number one seat so they can
play a 16 rather than being like a five,
you know,
and playing a 12. I don't know. I didn't
do a fucking math on that. Um, all right,
let's get into the, um, let's
get into the fucking wall.
Let us the letters for the week.
I need a man's advice.
Well,
what the fuck are you emailing
me for a long time fan?
Recent subscriber to the podcast?
I had no idea. I'm sorry. Well,
I never promoted.
Okay.
You know, so why would you
know about my fucking podcast?
Isn't there like nine zillion things on
the, you don't give yourself a break.
This is a zillion things on the
Internet is free porn on the Internet.
The very fact that you even
listen to two seconds of this is,
is an unbelievable comment.
Compliment.
Um, anyways, he said, uh,
I'm recent subscriber but I've obsessively
caught up and listen to like five
months of Monday morning podcast,
um,
breaking bad date nights,
Chappelle show all you stand up.
So he recent my hometown of Minneapolis.
I'm not a huge football fan.
What are we getting to hear?
All right, well thank you for, oh,
there was an arrow. Sit start here.
Thank you for all those compliments,
sir. All right. And he says,
hope you can see the Arrow down.
He Moy. Gee, I love emojis also
tipsy for courage to write this.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
He spelling Shinra. Anyway, she said,
I've been manifesting manifesting failings
for one of my best guy friends of 15
years. Now I'm 30 years
old and it seems like a no
brainer. Oh, this guy's drunk.
Braining or this woman's drunk,
whoever the fuck this is 30 years old
and it seems like a no braining that as
friends we make the go at
seeing if it could be more.
I don't, Jesus, let me see if
I can fucking get through this.
This is like an English person
or something. Who's drunk? Um,
I feel like what's holding me back are
I'm not 100% physically attracted to him.
I'm worried if it doesn't be, if
I'm worried, if it doesn't work out,
I risk the chance of losing a great
friend after a night of hanging out and
drinking. I texted him. So why have we
never messed around in our adult life?
To which she responded? Great
question. I'm not sure Jesus.
To which I said
your what?
Your epilepsy.
Okay.
E l. L. I. P. S. I. S that's not epilepsy.
Ellipsis indicates that
admission of words.
You know, people, you know, I'm
fucking dumb. Don't use this.
What the fuck is that?
Ellipsis?
What did I got to look this
up? Ellipsis. You know,
a lot of people will laugh at it,
but a lot of people also
want to hear the definition.
Ellipsis is a series of dots that usually
indicate an intentional admission of
words, sentence or a whole
section. Jesus Christ. Okay.
All right. My world. That's dot dot,
dot. I thought that said epilepsy.
You know what it is.
I start reading a word and when I can't,
I don't know what it is.
I panic like Mayor Menino and I
just throw out a fucking word.
Great question. He said, I'm not
sure. Dot Dot. Dot. To which point?
I said you're ellipsis indicates
and a mission of words.
Dot Dot, dot. All right.
You know what? Right there.
I'm not fucking you. I'm assuming
this is a woman at this point.
Um,
okay.
Yeah. Anybody who uses the word, you're
not even that the use the word ellipsis.
I can, I should own up to
my own stupidity or El Ep.
Epilepsies um,
indicates an admission
of words right there.
You're already putting him
on the defensive. You know,
you're already fucking like
mine. Fucking him. Anyways,
he said hoping to get them to
make the text move. He hasn't.
Oh, you thought that if you wrote, I'm
just gonna keep saying. Dot Dot, dot.
Cause I'm, I'm paranoid. Everybody's
laughing because I'm saying it wrong.
your.dot, dot indicates an emission
of words.dot, dot. She says,
hoping to get him to make the next
move. Dot Dot. Dot. He hasn't,
so is it on me to make the next move?
Is,
is the risk of running the relationship
ruining the relationship? Not Worth it?
Is it even worthy of your podcast?
Ah, what do I do if the person says,
I feel like we're good,
regardless of if you read this or not.
This is where I say thanks and
go fuck yourself. All right. Um,
well look,
if you're actually seriously want to, uh,
explore a relationship with somebody,
it's probably not a good idea to start
the relationship after a night of
drinking with texting.
Okay.
I would think, I think that's
a, that's a sober move.
Now if you just want to fuck the dude,
then yeah.
Drunk texting is great,
but I would leave out the big
words in Casey's a dummy like me.
MMM.
I Dunno. What is the next move?
Well, if you want to pursue it,
I would bring up the text
said, sorry. You know,
I was a little drunk when I texted
you, but, uh, I was, you know,
you know what? Don't do this.
This whole thing is set up wrong.
You just wrote, why have we never messed
around in our adult life? He didn't say,
how come you've never taken
me to a movie? Um, you,
you've basically the relationship
you're setting up here as a fuck buddy.
So if that's what you want,
I would say full steam ahead.
MMM.
If that isn't what you want,
I don't know how to finesse around
the drunk texts that you sent.
So why have we never messed around in our
adult life? Great question. I'm not sure
you're ellipsis saying that right.
Indicates in admission of words.
Yeah.
Who the fuck would ever text at this?
The guy's already drunk.
Okay.
He probably looks at what?
He's probably fucking held the
phone up to his drunk roommate.
What does that say?
Huh?
Why is she talking about epilepsy? I
don't know what to tell you ma'am. Um,
but if you want to hook up with
them, it's, it's there. It's there.
Come on. You're a female. Jesus Christ.
How hard can it be you putting it
out there like that? You're all,
as far as there being a love
connection. I don't, I don't,
I don't see it that I would
do something different. Golf,
fucking take a cooking class together.
You've got to do some up taking
you seriously, um, type of stuff.
I don't know. You're not that
physically attracted to the guy
it drunk texting him.
You know what you need to,
what you need some halftime adjustments.
That's what I would do. All right.
You're better than this. You, you can't,
you can't go hook up with a
guy that you were attracted to.
Don't settle for less sweetheart. All
right. You need to sober up like me.
You need to get out of the fog.
I'm doing it this week.
You do it to go hang out
with some different people.
Go find a good looking chap
that you're attracted to and uh,
you know, go fucking half a cup
of tea with them or some shit.
Whatever you do. I'm guessing you're
from somewhere else because, uh,
just the way you are,
some of the expressions beyond that word.
I couldn't read that I've never heard.
Oh, Jesus Christ. I don't know. Anyways,
that gave me a headache. All right.
Advice dealing with racist family.
Okay,
Bill. I'm a big fan and they need
advice about a problem with you may have
experienced,
uh,
my girlfriend is a different race than
me and my family is reacting in a racist
way about it. I didn't have
that problem. Thank God.
The problem is I am very close
to my family. I usually talk,
well of course you are.
I usually talk to my parents once a day,
so this means I have to deal
with their crap on a daily basis.
Um,
I love your grandmother comes to town
bit and that's similar to the kind of
bullshit that I'm dealing with on a
daily basis. Uh, here's the backstory.
My family is Jewish but not religious.
My parents are from Russia and our old
school white as far as they can see it,
as far as they see it,
racism is just the way it is.
And there is no shame in telling it like
it is by making ignorant statements.
Statements.
My folks told me exact words that
they want my girlfriend to be Jewish.
Okay.
But they,
what my folks told me exact words that
they want my girlfriends to be Jewish,
but that they would
settle for someone white.
Did you leave something out there,
sir? That doesn't make sense to me.
So my girlfriend is less
Lebanese. Slash. Mexican.
Okay.
Oh wait, wait a second. Wait a second.
Wait a second. Oh, your family is Jewish.
All right, now I get it. Sorry.
So fucking dumb this week. Um,
okay.
My folks told me that they want
my girlfriend to be Jewish,
but they would settle for someone white.
My girlfriend is Lebanese. Slash. Mexican.
Ever since I mentioned to her,
to my parents,
they've been making all kinds of
racist comments about her. Um,
they hate us or why can't you date
normal people of Jesus and there will be
problems you'll see. So I'm stuck. I can't
dump my girlfriend because I love her.
And two,
we have a great relationship in three.
Dumping her just because of racist
bullshit would make me a hypocrite,
but I can't cut off my parents
because I loved them too.
And they have otherwise been
wonderful and supportive. All my life.
I've tried explaining to my girlfriend
is not a problem and that she won't
change my relationship with them,
but my folks keep repeating
the same racist bullshit.
Any advice for dealing with my folks
would be greatly appreciated. Thanks.
And looking forward to seeing you the
next time you're in New York City.
All right? Well Dude, you
got to live your life.
You got to do what's right for you.
And um,
you know, hopefully your parents will
come around, but here's the deal, dude.
You're gonna outlive your parents,
so they're going to be long gone.
And if you do everything that they
want you to do, then when they,
when they're gone and you're living the
life they wanted you to live rather than
the life that you wanted to live.
Now if they what they want you to
do and what you want to do overlap,
then fucking by all means full steam
ahead. But if you really love this girl,
then I would,
I would stay with that.
All right?
You know, what are you, what are you
going to do the fuck you gonna do?
Fuck people you know,
fuck.
Would they think a bunch of
fucking mouth breathe and morons?
Why would you even listen to me?
I'm a mugging me. I'm a moron,
but I'm not a moron when it comes
to that shift. Fuck people live.
Live your life and let them,
uh, let them deal with it.
Math. Jesus. Fucking relationships are
hard enough. You don't need that shit.
Tell your parents to grow up. All right,
girlfriend, sleeping over. All right.
Hey Bill on 26 and my girlfriend of
about three months has been staying at my
house four to six nights a week.
Jesus Christ.
This started about the second week we
were dating when I asked her to stay over,
I only meant for that night.
I gave it time to get used to it.
Get used to someone being my bed.
It's killing me.
She lives with her dad and I understand
why she would rather stay with me.
She only has a toothbrush in my house,
so it's not like we moved in together,
but I have never lived
with a girlfriend before.
I feel like the
relationship moved too fast.
The worst part is I have to get up for
work at about 6:00 AM and feel like I
have to tip toe around so I don't wake
her and get dressed and I have to get
dressed in the dark. I'm
also tired in the, uh,
in the day from lack of sleep.
I've dropped subtle hints when
she hasn't spent the night.
Like I slept so good last night.
That's fucking hilarious.
Okay.
I also started to be loud in the
morning and turning on a lamp.
I think she got the hint,
but nothing has changed.
I asked my roommates it and
his girlfriend for advice,
but it seemed kind of blunt.
My roommate's girlfriend is in college,
so his girlfriend is only there on the
weekends and he misses her not being
there. So he thinks I'm being a bitch.
Uh, I don't want to break up with her.
Just find a nice way of saying,
go the fuck or I'll
see you tomorrow. Thanks
for the advice. By the way,
does everyone say go fuck yourself
at the end or do you add that Ah,
yeah, no. People say, go fuck yourself.
Um, yeah. This is the deal, ya,
your sound like you're a
younger person and yeah,
that's one of the hardest things you
have to learn is how to say what you're
saying.
I will say what you're feeling knowing
that the other person doesn't want to
hear it, but you say it in a healthy
way. So I would just say, um,
okay.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. Just say, listen,
we've got to talk about something.
And she'll say, what? And it's just like,
uh, listen, I love when you're over here.
I love spending time with you,
but four to six nights a week it's
affecting my sleep and you know,
my job and that type of thing. So, uh,
I'd like to have it be more
than like two nights a week.
It just kind of moved a little too
fast for me. And then she like,
what do you say? What are you
saying? Blah, blah, blah, blah.
And you just stay. No, I'm not saying
that. I'm not say I don't like you.
I'm just saying it moved too
quickly and this is on me. Um,
I didn't, I didn't want to
hurt your feelings and I
didn't know how to convey it.
I know I'm 26, but you know, this is an
area in my life that I need to work on.
So I'm trying to get better at this.
I'm just trying to communicate with you
what would make me happy so we can be
happy.
Yeah.
And then you know, if she wants
to pout and be like, wait,
if you think lamean the Eh, and just
want to be over here and then you know,
what the fuck are you gonna do?
You've only seen him for three months.
If she's going to act like a fucking baby,
then a letter.
But um,
you mentioned that she lives with her
dad and you understand why she would
rather stay with me. So is that guy
a dick? So if that guy is a dick,
then like she's like a stray cat and
you gave her some milk and now she's at
your door every fucking day. That
doesn't mean she likes you. That's,
that's not a hell,
that's not a fucking healthy reason for
it to be over there four to six times a
week. She's over there four to six
times a week because she loves you.
That's one thing.
But she's over there four to six times a
week because a dad's a fucking asshole.
MMM.
Then she's just kind of being codependent.
So,
but that's a whole other can of
worms and I don't bring up that part.
Do not bring up her dad, by the way, on
any fucking level. When you tell her,
just say, listen, this
moved really quickly and um,
all the bullshit that I just said,
just say it that way.
And if she's going to cry then like Hootie
and the blowfish set a long time ago,
let her cry.
All right.
Just let her fucking cry.
Okay.
And you know,
that's what they do when they get upset,
they cry.
So it doesn't mean you're a bad guy.
Just understand that she's crying because
you conveyed what's going to make you
happy.
Can you imagine if you did that?
If the shoe was on the other foot and
she was just saying, you watch an ESPN,
he watched sports center like three
times in a row. It's the exact same show.
Can't you just watch it once?
How many times do you have
to look at these highlights?
What do you think she would do if your
bottom lip started quivering and you
started crying and then tried to put the
entire relationship on that one little
thing,
you know?
Do you think she'd have any fucking guilt?
I don't think she would. So neither.
Should you grant watching ESPN three
times in a row and actually saying, hey,
could you not stay over here as much as
you know, they're not on the same level,
but you know what I'm saying?
So good luck to you, sir.
Just write down on a piece of paper.
That's what I used to do
because I wasn't good at it.
I just wrote it down on a piece of paper,
everything that I wanted to say and
I would draw a smiley face above it.
So I would remember not to say
it in an angry fucking way.
I know that sounds stupid, but it
worked for me, so good luck to you sir.
All right.
Yeah.
Two guys in a lady, two
guys and a girl. All right.
A their brother, man. Bill love you
show. My wife loves you. Stand up.
Ever since I showed her let it go,
I've got a situation on my hands here
that I would love to hear your input.
I had a falling out with one of my
closest friends about six years ago.
It was all because of a
girl that he said he was,
that he said was his first
love and apparently lost
virginity with the girl and
I hit it off.
And so we started going out.
We didn't want to hurt his feelings
since we were all best friends.
But after he found out he wanted
nothing to do with us. Uh,
which is understandable.
Is nothing worse than somebody banging.
Somebody used to be in love with,
right?
And then they come to you in a mature way.
It's the last thing you want.
You want it to sneak around so
you could be like, how dare you?
I thought you were friends
when they actually cut. Listen,
this is just something that we wanted
to talk to talk to you about because we
value our friendship
with you this same way.
We value the feeling that we bought in.
They're just being mature,
so you have to fucking sit there and
not call them cunt. That's the worst.
All right. Plowing ahead.
As the relationship grew,
she told me that she never was intimate
with him and that he didn't even know,
wait,
as the relationship grows,
she told me that she was never intimate
with him and that he didn't even know he
liked her that way. Oh,
and that she didn't.
He left that out there that she didn't
even know that he liked her that way.
Fast forward to present day,
I'm married to the same girl and have
two dogs and in the process of buying our
first home together, out of the
blue, out of the fucking blue,
my friend contacts me via
Facebook and keeps asking me
to go out with him.
When I say that,
my wife wants to tag along too.
Okay.
He keeps repeating the phrase.
We got to talk man,
man demand before we can start a new,
I just got all fucking turned around
in there. What the fuck just happened?
All right. The wife loves it.
Your relationship group, dude,
you fucked up a pronoun in there and
that just threw me right over the cliff.
Has the relationship grew?
She told me she never wanted to be,
she was never intimate with them.
Now wait a minute.
This guy said he lost his virginity tour.
Jesus Christ.
It's like a soap opera.
Okay,
so you married the girl.
He got two dogs and in the process
of buying for is out of the blue.
My friend contacted me via Facebook and
keeps asking me to go out with them off
to have a drink. All
right. When I say that,
that my wife wants to tag along too,
we keeps repeating the phrase we gotta
talk man to man before we start a new,
should I go?
Okay?
MMM.
Uh,
no.
Okay.
No,
no you shouldn't.
You shouldn't because
cause he's a fucking Weirdo.
He sounds like he still has
a lock of her hair someplace.
Got To start,
man to man,
they'll give me a fee still fucking
that's why the f wait, wait a second.
Why does he want to hang out with you?
He could walk away that easily.
How good of friends were you?
Okay.
You know, if you guys just watch games
together cause you work together,
you went to school for a couple
of years together. I mean,
I think it's a fucking rap. Sounds like
you've got a great thing with your wife.
Why do you want to bring this guy over
and then what?
Then what he wants to see what she
looks like. That's weird, dude.
That sets single white female shit.
I wouldn't, should you go? No,
I wouldn't go fuck him.
Yeah.
All right. This is the deal. You want
to hang out with us for a couple?
See us that way. Other than that,
you know, I can't fucking help you.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
Fuck that. I wouldn't go
stay with your wife. All right.
Three way relationship, sir.
Billion of orange. I like
that one. It's a very, uh,
I feel like I just get knighted.
Well, the fucking creamsicle. Um,
thanks for the podcast, man.
I'll try to keep this short.
So my girlfriend and I
off. Fuck. You know what?
I forgot to read the other
advertising there. Hold on a second.
Let me fucking read this real
quick. Um, he voice everybody.
If you're an entrepreneur
and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a high
rise window view? Fancy Pants office?
Oh, do you want them to know
you're sitting there and
you're underwears with he
voice? You can create the appearance
of an entire building, sales,
customer service, tech support, you
name it. They'll think you got it.
Give your customers the royal
treatment with the voice.
He voice will forward your
business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are, he voice.
We'll find you don't have time
to take a call. No biggie.
It's Raji a voicemail and you can read
it at your convenience as an email he
voiced not only gives you an edge
over the competitors, competitors,
it takes away the edge the big
companies have over you right now.
That's the big selling right there for me.
I don't know about you,
but that's the one I love anyways,
and right now you could try.
He voice for free for 30 days.
Go to a voice.com calm or just check,
uh,
go to the podcast page at [inaudible]
dot com and click on the voice banner.
Last but certainly not least,
stamps.com everyone a pretend you
have a wad of cash in your hand.
Now imagine throwing it in the trash. All
right, that's exactly what you're doing.
If you're leasing one of those expensive
postage meters for your small business,
longterm commitments, maintenance
and reset fees, expensive ink,
it's all crazy.
I know a better way.
Use stamps.com with stamps.com you can
get all the benefits of a postage meter
and more at a fraction of the cost.
Just use your own computer and printer
to get official US postage for any
envelope, any package,
any class of mail plus,
no more time consuming
trips to the post office.
Everything you would
do at the post office,
you
could
do it
right@homefromyourowndeskwithstampsdotcomiusestamps.com
to
send
out my DVDs to send out my tor tee
shirts and to send out my new fancy pants
posters. Then I'm going to have for my
upcoming shows in DC, Philly in New York.
Uh, right now use my last day Barbie.
You are our for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer includes a digital
scale and up to $55 free
postage. Don't wait. You son of a
bitch. Go to stamps.com right now.
Before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr. All right, back to the
final letter of the podcast here.
Okay. How about those Bruins?
Going down to Florida,
showing those two teams down there,
how the game's played.
Three way relationships are
built, sir, a billion of orange.
Thanks for the podcast, man.
I'll try to keep this short.
So my girlfriend and I are 25 and
invent together for about four years.
Things aren't great,
but they aren't horrible either.
Recently we started hanging out more
with her best friend and everyone,
whenever we hang out,
it's always a great time.
Her friend has been in
a bit of a relationship,
dry spell lately and recently
my girlfriend told me that
they've been discussing
the possibility of us starting a
threeway relationship. All right.
Okay.
I don't need to read any more dough it
they'll always says my girlfriend and I
have already gone down this road before
with minimal complications, but that
was primarily a sex only relationship.
Whereas this new one would
probably be more serious. Well,
you fucking Jack tripper.
How would it be more serious?
You're going to live with the two of them.
Oh,
that was a three's company reference
for anybody under the age of 50. Um,
the problem is I'd really
like to date the friend.
I think that we could make this trio work,
but I could see myself liking the friend
more than my current girlfriend and
fucking the whole thing up for everyone.
I also think that breaking up with my
girlfriend at the four years just to date
of best friend is a cut move and
therefore is off the table. Finally,
this fucking Shit, the
fucking question. Sorry.
So should I encourage this three way as
it's the only way I'll ever get to date
the friend,
which seems quite cunty or should I
just break up with the girlfriend?
Forget about the whole thing
and move west to start fresh.
Okay,
thanks again. And Go fuck yourself. Pleat.
Ps, come do a Gig in Maine before you get
okay.
Too Big for your freckles
and only do stadium gigs.
Um, first of all, sir,
you are a fucking hero and you are living
a life life right now that most men
only fantasize about, myself
included. That's fucking tremendous.
That is a tremendous,
okay
situation to have your cell phone.
You know what I say?
I say you fuck them both then
you her and then you fucking,
you move west and start a fresh, that's
what you do. And that's not a dirty move.
Okay. Because what's your girlfriend
is doing all right? She's into women.
She's in the bolt, but you're not going
to marry this woman. All right? This girl,
she's, she's rogue. She's a renegade.
She's going to get a pilot's
license to fly around.
The fucking world is Amelia Earhart.
Man, you don't tie this woman down.
Okay.
All right. Fuck that. You're not going
to marry her. You know you're not,
but you didn't want to
friend. All right, so
why don't you just do it?
I say you fucking both.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right. It's not a cut
move. They brought it up.
You don't think your
girlfriend's being selfish here.
Okay.
She's not.
She's sitting there risking her friendship
with her girlfriend to drag you into
the fold. The whole thing's for, there's
no fucking relationship here, sir.
You're a fuck stick. And by all
means, let them use you as such.
Get yourself some condoms.
Have a great time.
I'd have my suitcase packed right
outside the fucking bedroom door,
right? Don't do the porky pig.
Yeah, yeah. DDD. That's all folks.
And you're fucking out of there.
Okay.
God bless you. God bless you. But that's
Jesus Christ. People Shit on Maine.
People make fun of that state. That's,
that's considered a problem in Maine.
Everybody,
it's God's country up there.
Blue potatoes,
fresh air.
Yeah.
Fucking threesomes. They've got to
do something to stay warm. All right,
that's the podcast for this week,
everybody. I hope you enjoyed it.
Hope you have a wonderful week.
Um, I'm going to fucking, I dunno.
Go get myself some green juice is
something I'm laying off the stokes.
I'm laying off the bows feast
or famine with me. All right?
I'm done with this shit.
Uh,
okay.
Somehow still in great shape though.
I don't know what happened.
It's probably the liquid diet there.
All right, here's the wrap up everybody.
Now that the show's over, don't forget
to sign up for your free trial of Hulu.
Plus. CanNot stress that enough people.
This is TV watching for the future.
Okay? Hulu plus, let you binge on
thousands of hit TV shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV, PC, smartphone,
or tablet. Support this podcast dammit.
And get an extended free trial of Hulu.
Plus,
when you go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu
plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com,
Hulu plus.com. Excuse me. Slash Bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill. Um, all right,
so I got some great gigs coming up.
Um,
and I'm playing three legendary theaters.
I'm going to be at Constitution Hall,
Dar Constitution Hall,
right down the street from the
Federal Reserve. Everybody, you know,
I want to take pictures and sell DVDs
in front of the Federal Reserve after my
show. I know I won't be able to. All
right. And judging by the Greenpeace 30,
I don't feel like getting arrested for
any sort of fucking terrorism or whatever.
But,
um,
let me get to my podcast page here so
I can get you the dates on these season
three.
Awesome.
Just going to be legendary nights,
uh, for myself. Uh, here we
go. Here we go. All right.
On November 7th,
dark constitution hall in Washington DC.
Deal with that one,
everybody. That one is, uh,
that's where Eddie Murphy taped.
Delirious. All right. Enough said,
um, I did that. I've performed
there one other time,
but I was there with Jim Norton,
Jim Brewer and David Tell on the
antisocial network tour. It was awesome.
And I was really hoping when I came out
there they'd have that electric blue
carpet for some reason I feel like
Eddie had the blue carpet. Um,
but I think it was just a stage and it
was, it was awesome. So to actually,
I thought I'd never get to go there again.
Um,
so the fact that I'm going to be there,
it's going to be an extra special show
and a really looking forward to it.
And then on the eighth I'm doing the
beacon two shows at the beacon theater.
Um,
and then on the ninth I'm doing
two shows at the tower theater. Um,
it's just, it's just going to be awesome.
Beacon theater. Obviously, you know,
almond brothers do that.
The beacon run every fucking year there.
And I've done a number of benets
benefits there. I did the,
when I did the night at too many
stars when I did the Steve jobs bit.
Ah, that's where I take that
one. So, um, yeah, it's,
it's amazing to be able to come back
there and that people are buying that many
tickets. So I want to thank all
you guys for that. And as always,
dude, I called it Versie New
Jersey's own, Paul Versey,
Paul Benito,
Mussolini versa.
We'll be opening for me and it's just
going to be an awesome time and I'm really
looking forward to it.
And I got this feel as whole new chunk
of material coming so I'm beyond psyched
to go out and you know,
work it out this week in La and have it
ready to go in November. All right guys,
that's the uh, who's
playing tonight. The G men,
the giants trying to not go
oh and seven through Paul.
He is the greatest giants fan of all time.
He,
no matter how all in one all went to Olin,
three o and four.
I have to every fucking
week their own four. Dude,
I'm telling you right now they're
going to finish nine and seven.
The giants are going to go night.
You heard it here first.
They go in [inaudible] 93 the rest,
he was saying last night I
was hanging out with them.
He was still talking positive.
He says they're all one six he goes,
they're going to win this guy.
I think he's going to set that.
They're going to finish eight and eight
all right. Fucking phenomenal fan.
I got to respect them for that.
Other than that,
I make fun of everything else he does.
All right. That's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll see you.